ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY WEDNESDAY
JANUARY TWENTY SEVENTH TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN. WE DO NOT
YET HAVE A QUORUM SO WE WILL
OPERATE AS A SUB COMMITTEE WE
HAVE ENOUGH MEMBERS FOR THAT AND
WE. HAVE AN AUTHOR.
SCOTT WHERE WE'LL GO TO ITEM
NUMBER TWO HR SEVENTY ONE.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN STONE AND
MEMBERS AND PLEASE TO PASS ARE
PRESENT H. R. SEVENTY ONE WHICH
CELEBRATES JANUARY TWENTY SECOND
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. AS THE
FORTY FIFTH ANNIVERSARY OF THE
ROE V. WADE CASE.
AS I'M SURE YOU'RE ALL THE WAY
AWARE ROBY WADE WAS DECIDED IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE AND IT
WAS A PIVOTAL SUPREME COURT CASE
THAT SECURED EVERY WOMAN'S RIGHT
TO ACCESS AN ABORTION.
AS SOON AS WOMEN ONE THAT'S
RIGHT HOWEVER THERE HAVE BEEN
COUNTLESS ORGANIZED MOVEMENTS TO
REVERSE IT YET FORTY FIVE YEARS
LATER ROE V. WADE HAS STOOD
STRONG. EFFETE WE WISH TO
RECOGNIZE IN THIS RESOLUTION.
HR SEVENTY ONE ALSO COMMEMORATE
PLANNED PARENTHOOD AS ONE OF THE
PARTNERS IN CALIFORNIA THAT AT
ONE OF OUR PARTNERS AND ONE OF
CALIFORNIA'S LEADING PROVIDERS
OF QUALITY AFFORDABLE HEALTH
CARE AND EDUCATIONAL SERVICES
FOR WOMEN IN NEED. FOR OVER A
CENTURY SERVING APPROXIMATELY
EIGHT HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
PATIENTS A YEAR SEVENTY FIVE
PERCENT OF WHICH ARE WITHIN A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY PERCENT OF THE
POVERTY LEVEL. PLANNED
PARENTHOOD IS A TRUSTED PROVIDER
OFFERING PRIMARY PREVENTATIVE
CARE THAT IS VITAL TO WOMEN'S
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH.
IN PARTICULAR PLANNED PARENTHOOD
HAD PROVIDED THESE MUCH NEEDED
SERVICES IN RURAL COMMUNITIES
WITCHES.
NEAR AND DEAR TO MY HEART WHERE
SERVICES ARE SCARCE
AND COST PROHIBITIVE. DESPITE
THE SERVICES AND EDUCATIONAL
MATERIALS THIS ORGANIZATION
PROVIDES THAT HELPS LOW INCOME
WOMEN WHO MAY OTHERWISE NOT
RECEIVE CARE. BOTH PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AND THE FUNDAMENTAL
RIGHTS INVOLVING FEMALE
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE IS
CONTINUALLY PUTTING QUESTION BY
OPPOSING FORCES. THIS IS WHY I
AM HERE TO PRESENT HR SEVENTY
ONE TO INCREASE AWARENESS OF THE
VITAL SERVICES THOUSANDS OF
WOMEN AND MEN RELY ON AT PLANNED
PARENTHOOD. AND TO PROTECT
PROTECT THE RIGHTS OF WOMEN ONE
FORTY FIVE YEARS AGO IN THE ROE
V. WADE CASE WITH ME TODAY IS
ANDREA SAN MIGUEL FROM PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU
S. WITH WARNING YES MY NAME'S
ANDREAS AND THE GAL I'M NOT
POLICY ADVOCATE FROM PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES OF
CALIFORNIA. REPRESENTING THAT
PENSIONS RESERVE THAT THE STATE.
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHORAND
COMMITTEE FOR TAKING UP SEVENTY
ONE THIS MORNING IN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT. ON AS
YOU HEARD NEXT MONDAY IS THE
FORTY FIFTH ANNIVERSARY OF THE
UNITED STATES SUPREME COURT
LANDMARK DECISION ON ROE V.
WADE.
THIS HISTORIC RULING AFFIRMS
THAT EVERY WOMAN HAS THE
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT TO AN ABORTION
WHICH IS A MEDICAL PROCEDURE
THAT NEARLY ONE AND FOR WOMEN.
WILL AVAIL HERSELF OF IN HER
LIFETIME.
ACCESS TO REPURPOSE HEALTHCARE
INCLUDING ABORTION ENSURES THAT
WOMEN HAVE THE RIGHT TO DECIDE
IF.
WHEN AND WITH WHOM TO HAVE
CHILDREN.
THIS CONTROL OVER ONE'S BODY IS
CRITICAL FOR ECONOMIC AND SOCIAL
WELL BEING.
IF YOU SUPPORT WOMEN HAVING
ACCESS TO BASIC HEALTH CARE.
THAT WE MUST CONTINUE TO ENSURE
WOMEN HAVE THE RIGHT TO
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE.
IT IS IMPORTANT FOR CALIFORNIA
WHICH IS HOME TO NEARLY TWENTY
MILLION WOMEN.
TO FOR A TO RECOGNIZE THESE
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHTS ESPECIALLY.
DURING THIS TIME WHEN PROVIDERS
OF REPRODUCTIVE AND SEXUAL
HEALTH CARE LIKE PLANNED
PARENTHOOD ARE UNDER SERIOUS AN
UNRELENTING ATTACK SIMPLY FOR
FOR PROVIDING THIS CARE. SO WE
URGE YOUR AYE VOTE ON SEVEN ONE
THINKING.
THANK YOU THAT WE DO HAVE A
QUORUM SO BEEN A PAUSE AND
ESTABLISH A QUORUM CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE HERE CUNNINGHAM
CHAO.
CHIU. GARCIA.
HOLDEN KALRA.
KILEY.
MAIN CHINA THREATS.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A QUORUM.
ANYONE ELSE LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT.
HELLO TO SECOND THAT'S
WOULD YOU DO THAT AGAIN FOR THE
RECORD YOUR. KATHY SURE ON
BEHALF OF THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
CIGNA BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
IT'S KALRA.
THIS EMBRACE WANNA THANK YOU
SHARE SIMILAR THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD I KNOW.
FIRST HAND.
IN SAN JOSE CERTAINLY IN AND OF
THIS THE CASE THROUGHOUT THE
STATE HOW IMPORTANT.
THE SERVICES OF PLANNED
PARENTHOOD ARE CERTAINLY.
AND.
THE TO. THE VALUE YOU KNOW OF
OF THE ROAD THE WAY CASES STAND
THE TEST OF TIME.
A IN TERMS OF THE VALUE OF
RESPECTING WOMEN'S RIGHT. OF TO
THEIR PRIVACY THE RIGHT TO THEIR
ABILITY TO CHOOSE.
THE DISMAY AND MAKE DECISIONS
ON BEHALF OF THEIR BODY OF AND
THE REPRODUCTIVE CHOICES I THINK
IT'S CRITICAL AND MORE IMPORTANT
THAN EVER ESPECIALLY GIVEN
ATTACKS THAT WE SEE CONSTANTLY.
TIME AND AGAIN AT THROUGHOUT
THE THE NATION OF.
EVEN IN THE STATE WE OFTENTIMES
SEE EFFORTS.
TO UNDERCUT.
AND UNDERMINE OTHER VALUABLE HE
WEIGHED A AS WELL AS THE
SERVICES OF. AN UNCRITICAL WELL.
CLEARLY PARTNERS AYE PLANNED
PARENTHOOD OF COURSE OFFER A
WIDE RANGE ARRAY OF SERVICES AND
MANY WOMEN. I WOULD I'VE
CERTAINLY M. LOOK AT THE DATA
FROM THE LOCAL CHAPTERS PLAN
PART OF MY DISTRICT. UP MANY
WOMEN GET OUT. ALMOST THEIR
ENTIRE HEALTH SERVICES FROM
PLANNED PARENTHOOD THAT THING WE
NEED TO RECOGNIZE THAT AS WELL
BUT I THINK YOU AND I AM
CERTAINLY. WELL. OVER LIKE TO
MAKE A OF LOW MOTION OF THE BILL
TO THINK WE CAN.
DO WE DO HAVE A MOTION. AND A
SECOND TO THE MOTION IS THAT THE
RESOLUTION BE ADOPTED. OTHER
COMMENTS QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS.
ALRIGHT SINGER WAS COVERING
MIKLOS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
CHAIR AND AND AND.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER OUT KALRA.
AS A FORMER. BOARD MEMBER OF
THE MAR MONTY PLANNED PARENTHOOD
UP A BOARD I AM IT'S AN HONOR
FOR ME TO BE HERE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF PLANNED PARENTHOOD.
IN SALINAS THAT FACILITY IS
THERE BECAUSE WE ADVOCATED FOR
THEM TO MOVE INTO OUR COMMUNITY
AND OPEN A CLINIC IN THE MINUTE
THEY DID IT WAS IMMEDIATELY.
FALL AND THEM THE KIND TO
PROVIDE SERVICES THAT ARE
PROVIDED YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT
SIMPLY MEMBER KALRA.
ARE THE REPRODUCTIVE. HEALTH
SERVICES THAT ALL WOMEN AND MEN
DESERVE AND.
VERY LITTLE OF THE WORK
ACTUALLY DONE IS ABORTION
SERVICES BUT IT.
THAT WOMEN HAVE THE CHOICE AND
SO I'M I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU THEY MOTION IS THAT
THE RESOLUTION BE ADOPTED COLOR
OAKLEY STONE AYE STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM. CHOW. CHOW AYE CHU.
CHIU AYE GARCIA. HOLDEN KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY. KILEY NO
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE RADIUS.
REYES AYE.
GARCIA GARCIA AYE.
THANK YOU THAT RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED BY THIS COMMITTEE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH YOU VERY MUCH.
SO THAT BRINGS US TO ITEM NUMBER
ONE AB TWELVE FORTY EIGHT.
GLORIA AND AS HE MOVES FORWARD
I'LL TAKE A MOTION ON THE
CONSENT AGENDA.
SO THERE IS A MOTION.
AND A SECOND ON THE CONSENT
AGENDA.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL STONE AYE
STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM. CHAO.
BUT THE CAN.
CONSULT CHAO AYE TO.
CHIU AYE GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE
HOLDEN.
KALRA.
HOLDEN ON CONSENT.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY. KILEY AYE
MAIENSCHEIN. LANE CHEN AYE RAAS.
PRIUS AYE.
IF YOU THAT BILL IS OUT THAT IS
A BE. FIFTEEN TWENTY SIX BY
MISTER KALRA RIGHT
I'M NUMBER ONE MR GLORIA PLEASE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS I THINK TO
ALLOW THE PRESENT AB TWELVE
FORTY EIGHT. THIS IS SIMILAR
LAST YEAR'S AB TWO THIRTY THREE
WHICH YOU WAS UNANIMOUSLY PASSED
BY THIS COMMITTEE.
THE BILL ENHANCES THE DIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS AND PROTECTS
THE RIGHTS OF STUDENTS TO WEAR
CULTURAL ADORNMENTS AT
GRADUATION CEREMONIES. UNDER
EXISTING LAW SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ARE PERMITTED TO DEVELOP
REASONABLE DRESS CODE POLICIES
THAT FOSTER POSITIVE LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT AND PROTECT THE
SAFETY AND WELFARE OF STUDENTS.
UNFORTUNATELY SCHOOL GOVERNING
BOARDS ADMINISTRATORS HAVE A
TEENY ENFORCED WHAT ARE KNOWN AS
NON DORMANT POLICIES THAT
PREVENT STUDENTS FROM WEARING
CULTURAL CEREMONIAL AND
RELIGIOUS ADORNMENTS AT
GRADUATION CEREMONIES.
SEVERAL INCIDENTS INVOLVING
NATIVE AMERICAN STDENTS
CALIFORNIA ATTEMPTING TO WEAR
EAGLE FEATHERS REVEAL THAT THESE
POLICIES PREVENT STUDENTS FROM
RECOGNIZING CULTURAL TRADITIONS
ARE CELEBRATING THEIR ACADEMIC
ACHIEVEMENT. FOR THOSE OF YOU
WHO MAY BE UNFAMILIAR THE EAGLE
FEATHER IS A SYMBOL REPRESENTING
PERSONAL ACHIEVEMENT AND ONCE
PASSAGE INTO ADULTHOOD. OF THIS
PROGRAM THIS PROBLEM HOWEVER IS
NOT RESERVED R. UNIQUE JUST
NATIVE AMERICANS IN OUR STATE.
IN NEARBY ELK GROVE AN AFRICAN
AMERICAN STUDENT WAS PROHIBITED
FROM PARTICIPATING IN HIS
GRADUATION CEREMONY.
AFTER REFUSING TO REMOVE A KENTE
CLOTH.
BUT PROTECTING A PEOPLE'S RIGHT
TO WEAR CULTURAL GARMENTS A
SCHOOL GRADUATION CEREMONIES AB
TWELVE FORTY EIGHT ENHANCES THE
DIVERSITY CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC
INSTITUTIONS. MIND TENSION THIS
YEAR IS TO SYDNEY IS TO SIT DOWN
WITH THE OPPOSITION TO NEGOTIATE
LANGUAGE THAT BALANCES THE
STUDENT'S RIGHT TO. FREEDOM OF
EXPRESSION WHILE.
WITH THE SCHOOLS EQUALLY
UNQUESTIONED RIGHT AT TO PREVENT
DISRUPTION OF IMPORTANT SCHOOL
FUNCTIONS WITH ME TODAY AS I
HAVE CATHOLIC FOR AND THE
AMERICAN CIVIL LIBERTIES UNION.
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU EITHER.
THANK YOU WHEN ISN'T SUPPORT THE
MORNING CATHY SURE ON BEHALF OF
THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA.
AB TWELVE FORTY EIGHT IS AN
INFANT NEEDED CLARIFICATION OF
THE RIGHTS OF STUDENTS TO WEAR
RELIGIOUS CEREMONIAL OR CULTURAL
ADORNMENTS AT SCHOOL GRADUATION
CEREMONIES.
THE SEMINAL SO YOU S. SUPREME
COURT CASE OF TINKER VERSUS TO
MOINS INVOLVES EXPRESSION BY THE
WEARING OF AN ITEM. IN THAT CASE
BLACK ARMBANDS TO PROTEST THE
VIETNAM WAR.
THE SUPREME COURT HELD THAT
STUDENTS RIGHT TO FREEDOM OF
EXPRESSION ALLOW THIS TYPE OF
PROTEST SO LONG AS IT DID NOT
DISRUPT THE OPERATION OF THE
SCHOOL. THIS TYPE OF EXPRESSION
IS ALSO PROTECTED UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION.
STUDENTS SHOULD EQUALLY BE ABLE
TO WEAR ADORNMENTS AS AN
EXPRESSION OF THEIR RELIGIOUS OR
CULTURAL HERITAGE AGAIN AS THE
BILL MAKES CLEAR SO LONG AS
DOING SO IS NOT DESTRUCTIVE.
BY CLARIFYING THE LAW AB TWELVE
FORTY EIGHT WILL PROTECT
STUDENTS RIGHTS AND OFFER
GUIDANCE TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS SO
AS TO REDUCE THE NEED FOR
UNNECESSARY LITIGATION.
AS ANYONE WHO HAS ATTENDED A
HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATION CEREMONY
KNOWS IT IS A JOYFUL AN
IMPORTANT CEREMONY FOR STUDENTS
AND THEIR FAMILIES.
IT IS A TIME FOR CELEBRATION NOT
ONLY OF THE INDIVIDUAL STUDENT
AND WHAT HE OR SHE HAS JUDGED
ACCOMPLISHED BUT ALSO OF
EVERYONE WHO HELPED GET THE
STUDENT TO THAT POINT.
THE FAMILY AND THE HERITAGE OF
THE STUDENT.
IT IS ALSO THE MARKING OF AN
IMPORTANT TRANSITION.
STUDENTS WHO ARE MARKING THAT
TRANSITION SHOULD CONSISTENT
WITH OUR CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS
BE ABLE TO WEAR THE ADORNMENTS
THAT THEIR CULTURES USE ON SUCH
OCCASIONS.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT AB TWELVE
FORTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
A TEAR MEMBERS FRIGHTENINGLY NO
BEHALF OF THE SAME NAME AS
MANAGE EMISSIONS IN THE SALMON
WHAT BAND OF MISSION INDIANS IN
SUPPORT.
CHAIR MEMBER SEAN FLANIGAN ABOUT
OFFICE QUAN TRAVESTY DIEGO IN
STRONG SUPPORT MAKE THANK YOU.
IT.
SO WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND THE
SECOND ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS NANCY CHINA SINCE BEEN
ALSO ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL BOARDS ASSOCIATION.
ONCE AGAIN WE MUST REGRETFULLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL OF REALLY DUE
TO THE APPROACH THAT IT TAKES SO
PAGE FIVE THE SECOND PARAGRAPH
IN YOUR ANALYSIS POSITS THAT.
UNDER THIS BILL THAT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS COULD STILL AVAIL
THEMSELVES OF THE STANDARD THAT
SAYS THAT.
THEY COULD BORROWED ADORNMENT
IF IT WAS LIKELY TO CAUSE A
SUBSTANTIAL DISRUPTION BUT UNDER
A LEGAL FRAMEWORK ESTABLISHED IN
THIS BILL WE FIND THAT WE WOULD
NOT HAVE.
THE SOLD LEGAL FOUNDATION TO
USE SUCH A DEFENSE AND IN FACT
THE VERY PROPONENTS OF THIS BILL
WOULD LIKELY SU LOCAL EDUCATION
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IF THEY TRY TO
AVAIL THEMSELVES OF THIS. SO
THAT IS OUR CONCERN WITH THE
APPROACH IN THIS BILL WE THINK
THAT IT ACTUALLY.
IT IT GOES FARTHER THAT IT
NEEDS TO TO ACHIEVE WHAT WE
UNDERSTAND IS THE INTENT OF THE
AUTHOR SO WE VERY MUCH LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THE
CONVERSATION. AND HOPEFULLY.
COMING TO SOME MUTUALLY
AGREEABLE AND SOLUTION IN THE
FUTURE AND AND ONE VERY MINOR
FACTUAL CORRECTION THE ELK GROVE
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT DID NOT
PROVIDE A A STUDENT FROM
PARTICIPATING IN GRADUATION.
I DON'T THINK IT'S MATERIAL TO
SEE S. B. A.'S POSITION BUT I
JUST WANTED TO GET THAT ON THE
RECORD UNDER THE SITUATIONAL
CERTAINLY MISHANDLED.
BUT THE STUDIO WAS NOT
PREVENTED FROM.
SPITTING IN THE CEREMONY.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
RIGHT SEEN NONE WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
AS GLORIA NO THAT.
WELL THIS PASSED THROUGH THIS
COMMITTEE FAIRLY READILY AYE I
UNDERSTAND CSPA ITS CONCERNS AND
AND THE NOTE FOR DISRUPTION BUT
I THINK. WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS
BALANCE THE NEED FOR SOME
CULTURAL PROTECTIONS HERE FOR
STUDENTS WHO. AND WHO DO HAVE.
SOMETHING OF CULTURAL
SIGNIFICANCE THAT THEY WANT TO.
BRING TO A CEREMONY LIKE THIS TO
TO BE ABLE TO CELEBRATE TIED
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK ON THIS
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN. OTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM.
MEMBERS.
ALRIGHT SINGER MR GLORY MAKE
CLOTHES RESPECTFULLY ASK ANY
TYPE OF.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND THE MOTION IS TO PASS
KALRA PLEASE STONE BY STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM AYE CHAO.
CHAO AYE CHU. CHU AYE GARCIA AYE
GARCIA AYE HOLDEN. HOLDEN AYE
KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE RADIUS. PRIUS
AYE.
A BILLS OUT.
THANK YOU WE WILL NOTE FOR THE
RECORD THAT MISTER CHIU IS PLUS
ONE HERE TODAY AND. YOU ARE
ALWAYS WELCOME AT THE DYESS EVEN
THIS.
WITH WITH YOUR CHILD THIS IS
COMMITTEE IS NOTHING IF NOT FOR
FAMILY FRIENDLY.
BECAUSE THAT IS NOT STROLLER OF.
JUST GET THAT STROLLER UP THE
STAIRS OKAY SO WE DO HAVE SOME
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ON OKAY SO HR SEVENTY ONE.
THE ITEM NUMBER TWO BUY A COPY
AERO.
CALL THE ABSALOM.
CUNNINGHAM.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE.
AND THEN ON CONSENT CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS CUNNINGHAM AYE
CUNNINGHAM AYE.
AND THAT WOULD THAT COMPLETES
OUR BUSINESS FOR TODAY THANK YOU
ALL VERY MUCH FOR A QUICK
HEARING AND WE ARE ADJOURNED